yes now with more are the authors of the
book those great guys who wrote let
Trump be Trump the inside story of his
rise to the presidency Fox News
contributor David bossy and for Trump
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski all
right guys the inspector general's
report from me it was very sad I you
know I had seen and followed very
closely for so many months all of the
all of the wrongs all of the biases that
were so obvious and then in the end
after you know this huge report we've
got okay that they they kept their
personal biases at the door and I don't
want to spend a lot of time on this
because I want to talk about the good
stuff the president's doing but David
bossy what's your take on it all well
first of all this guy's a agent struck
this FBI agent needs to be fired and
fired immediately but he was involved
let's remember he was involved in the
Hillary Clinton interview he was
involved in Cheryl Mills and Huma
Aberdeen's interview he was involved in
in Mike Flynn's interview if this is
outrageous that he is the center of this
he is clearly biased somebody who hated
this president and still does to this
day it is outrageous that he's still
employed by the FBI but more importantly
did the judge who issued the FISA
warrant know that he was involved did
was was was this man involved with
leaking the the man afford information
two years ago this investigation we've
been going on two years August and he
was involved eleven days later we know
that that struck that there was a leak
of the man afford information so this
this is a very incestuous very bad group
within the FBI that's given them but we
all know this and and corey lewandowski
i mean you know what david says is
nothing that that isn't obvious and yet
tonight Paul Manafort
has been ordered to jail all right that
guy didn't work for the FBI he wasn't
biased he wasn't handling Hillary
Clinton in the anti-trump and exposing
his biases now manna Fork is going to
jail where he's got a ten million dollar
bond how do you how do you level this
out and your mom
that we've got such a great system look
judge the here's the real problem that
we have the inspector general's report
was very clear about one thing which the
mainstream media refuses to cover
Hillary Clinton took classified emails
put it on an unclassified server and
those emails were hacked or at least
accessible by a foreign entity why is
there not a criminal referral for
Hillary Clinton for not protecting
classified information you can you think
of whatever you want about Paul Manafort
and you know Paul and I aren't the best
of friends but the fact that Paul
Manafort went off to jail today when
Hillary Clinton continues to walk free
when the IG says that you took
classified emails put them on an
unclassified server and it says in the
report that someone accessed that server
from a foreign country and if you
remember how is that not a criminal
referral well well I'm going to tell you
why
okay because I don't think it wouldn't
make a darn bit of difference because I
want to know who's gonna prosecute her
but let me let me go now - whoa - David
bossy okay we got the World Cup the
president had a great week you know
would kim jong ganas agreeing to
denuclearization obama was out there
saying you know i'm gonna get I'm gonna
get the World Cup and I'm gonna get the
Olympics here he couldn't do anything
look he's had a great week the president
it's one of the great weeks of his
administration the lowest did the job
numbers today's unbelievable Louis in 40
jobless claims Louis in 44 years our
economy is humming this president got
elected because he said jobs jobs jobs
and he meant it
through deregulation through these tax
cuts through an entrepreneurial spirit
that he has brought to the presidency it
has been a great week on the economy it
has been a great week in him dealing
with North Korea trying to denuclearize
the Korean Peninsula is something that
is generationally important let me just
say about the World Cup the guy who used
to be the head of the American World Cup
said Oh Obama is gonna be able to get
this for us now that he's president and
in 2016 he said oh we can't have Donald
Trump because the cup will never come
here look again he proves every
badi wrong okay so Cory let's talk about
the those people who are all predicting
nuclear war and you know that the
President Trump doesn't know how to
negotiate he doesn't know what he's
doing but aside from all that I'm gonna
ask you a question I gotta gear off that
for a second how does this guy fly back
and forth to Singapore do all the
negotiating all this stuff that he's
doing and he's walking outside the White
House today just you know greeting a
bunch of press people and answering
every question he's on top of his game
how does he do this
judge Donald Trump is is a machine and I
mean that I've spent thousands of hours
with them he never sleeps he just
continues to work and that's why in the
first 18 months of this administration
he's been so successful go back and look
at what he talked about we're gonna have
4% growth they said you'll never get
there now the Fed is saying maybe it's
4.8%
because he never stops he never gives up
he keeps fighting he walked out and did
that impromptu press conference with Fox
today and I'm sure some of the staff
said oh no sir don't do that Donald
Trump is the best when he is Donald
Trump the book that Dave and I wrote let
Trump be Trump is why he is successful
because he does things outside the norm
who stayed up for 25 hours straight on
that airplane got off the plane and kept
on working he didn't go to bed for a
week like Hillary Clinton did before
every debate that week she was in bed
for longer than that but he doesn't
drink coffee does he no coffee look you
know Donald Trump coffee it's raw
adrenaline and diet coke and he just
keeps on going judgment and that's why
he wears out staff and that's why he's
successful he just has a different gear
than everybody else including the staff
whether it was on the campaign or at the
White House this guy works 20 hours a
day seven days a week and that's why our
economy is moving that's why he can
handle people are wondering how could he
do so many different things every single
day it's because he never stops he is a
hard-working incredibly smart diligent
guy who is doing an incredible job as
president and not only that he
celebrated his birthday this week
right alright David you gotta see lookee
lookee judge you have to remember the
press never complains now that this
president is not doing enough right they
complain that they can't keep up with
them I think it's a far cry from a
bottle who did nothing for eight years
well you know I wouldn't really used to
talk about 24/7 news they never really
knew what it meant until dr. drop into
the White House thanks for being with us
tonight